hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar integrating genomic
platforms and data and bio banks I am
Christina mahalik of labyrinth and I'll
be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
elaborate the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit why Bruce calm let's
get started you can post questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the Q&A box
which will open when you click on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the side window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the plane window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the cee button
located in the bottom left corner of
your web page and follow the process of
obtaining your credit I am now delighted
to present today's speaker Sammy amer
PhD director at the translational
genomics core partners healthcare
personalized medicine Harvard Medical
School Sammy amer is the director of the
translational genomics core of Partners
HealthCare personalized medicine where
he feels privileged to work with basic
and translational researchers across
partners healthcare to identify DNA RNA
and methylation markers and signatures
of diseases that can help d convolute
under
mechanisms at pathogenesis as well as
being leveraged in diagnostic and
clinical essays dr. amburn will now
begin his presentation the floor is all
yours thank you very much Christina for
that introduction thank you for inviting
me the for this to present this
presentation this webinar and
essentially what I'd like to talk to to
the audience today's is relating to how
we can integrate genomic data into a
biobank platform this slide shows my
disclosures I'm an employee Partners
HealthCare personalized medicine which
offers research in clinical genomic
services in an academic and
not-for-profit setting and for the
majority of this presentation I will be
sharing with the group and discussing
our experience in integrating genomics
platforms into the partners healthcare
database and there's two major
objectives for for this presentation and
the first objective is to be able to
describe the different genomics
platforms and technologies that could be
leveraged in DNA plasma or serum bio
banks and the second objective is to
also store strategies that allow easier
integration of that genomics data into
the existing infrastructure of the of
the biomech in a way that promotes
accessibility to data for researchers as
well as allow for ease of use of data
curing so to begin this discussion I'd
like to just give you an overview of the
partners healthcare biobank and the
partners healthcare biobank is there
auditory of consented patient samples
that is linked to the electronic medical
records of these stations and is
supplemented with health information as
well as family history from surveys that
are provided to the to the patient so
these are essentially self-reported
surveys that are collected and today we
we have more than 57,000 patients in the
partners healthcare system have
consented to participate in the body
bank and with actually done blood
collections for more than forty one
thousand patients and currently our
target is to consent 75,000 patients by
2018 the three major objectives of the
partners biobank is to advance you know
it's a killer research by allowing
immediate access to samples and data to
researchers and the second one is to
reduce the cost of research and so that
the purse sample or per patient
inclusion into a research study is
significantly less expensive than then
it would be if a researcher was to do it
outside of of the biobank so both of
these objectives are going to drive
medical research in order to improve
healthcare and essentially one can look
at this as the biobank allows for for
accessibility to large patient cohorts
to medical information as well as easy
access to different different sample
types from these patients and what our
biobank provides are consented DNA
plasma and serum plus samples and if a
medical researcher if a researcher is
interested in in one of these sample
types the cost per sample would be 20
235 dollars per sample however the
estimated cost if a researcher what to
what to collect these sample types
outside of the context of the biobank is
roughly between 300 to 1,000 dollars per
subject so clearly there are there are
major incentives to researchers working
within the partners healthcare system in
being able to access a biobank samples
as well as access to biobank patient
information this is just a general
outline of the operations of the
partners healthcare biobank essentially
there's four different components or
phases the first phases recruitment and
the recruitment of patients is either
done in person at the hospital during
their clinical visits or patients also
have an option to consent electronically
through the biobank portal system the
second phase or the second piece of the
second step in da and the biobank
operations their workflow is phlebotomy
or blood draws and both research and
clinical Obama's can draw blood from
patient samples we also collect samples
from clinical discords the third
component is sample and data management
and this is essentially a large IP and
and by firm Attucks infrastructure to be
able to track samples coming in link
them to medical health records of
patients as well as any genomics type
data that is that is produced in
downstream applications and the final
the final piece of the biobank
operations is of course sample and data
distribution essentially works was that
we've implemented to be able
to deliver samples back to different
researchers that they're interested in
as well be able to deliver different
types of data whether the medical
records data or genomic size data back
to investigators that are interested in
in the buyback is a different biobank
cohorts so what exactly does the biobank
provide investigators with it provides
essentially access to patient and the
cohorts that are consented for broad
research and broad-based research as
well as patients that are consented for
return of actionable results in addition
these patients are also consulted for
recontact for additional info or
additional sampling or inclusion in two
different studies investigators also can
access different types of sample types
essentially the main sample types that
we extract out of the blood draws our
serum plasma DNA with the we work with
collaborating studies investigators that
have their own kind of court analysis
and we can collect two additional types
from these collaborating studies that
are incorporated as part of the bio bank
sample repository and the other piece is
the investigators have access to
discarded tissue samples and all of
these as I mentioned before are
immediately available and are available
at a much lower cost than they would if
outside of the if they were collected
outside of the body the types of genomic
data are medical medical records data
that is provided to investigators
essentially right now we are offering
genomic data for 25,000 patients in
addition this information is linked to
the electronic medical records of these
patients as well as the self-reported
surveys and data on family history
lifestyle and environment and finally
we've also supplement
all of these different you know services
that are part of the buyback was
powerful instead of the art query tools
that allow you to essentially use the
EMR data electronic medical records data
as well as well as the genomic data to
be able to identify different course to
identify to accurately identify court
with a disease of interest as well as
identify controls within the population
for a given disease so what types of
information what types of health
information are linked to these samples
that are found in the biobank there's
two different major types of data one is
the clinical data and this includes both
coded data as well as text data coded
data includes essentially diagnosis
based on icd-9 or icd-10 codes
demographic data and that is that it's
provided by that is provided within the
electronic medical records as well as
any laboratory test data as well as the
you know medications data for a given
patient text data is essentially the
notes that are positions that are
excluded as part of the electronic
medical records that are provided by the
physicians discharge summaries operated
reports cardiology reports or pathology
reports and the second large component
type of data that is provided as part of
the health information that is linked to
samples is survey data and those are
self-reported the surveys that look at
or query family history environment
environmental circumstances as well as
any other kind of lifestyle related type
data
so what is the one of the
characteristics of the participants of
the partners healthcare bio bank
essentially it pretty much reflects the
the the population that is found in the
Northeast and in in Boston and the
majority of individuals that are
included in the biobank or Caucasians
eighty-three percent are white we have a
fifty-eight percent the forty-two
percent female-to-male ratio the
majority of patients are closer to the
50s and 60s age categories or age groups
and about fifty eight percent have of
the biobank participants have either
college or graduate degree and so it's
pretty reflective of the population that
that is that is a unique to Boston and
unique to the northeast and based on the
report on the icd-9 codes that are found
in the medical records and these this
table represents the different types of
phenotypes that are identifying patients
represented in the bio Vic and the the
the highest frequency phenotype that is
reported in joint pain however there's a
broad range of different types of
complex diseases that are found in these
patients including for example
hypercholesterolemia in about thirteen
thousand patients ischemic heart disease
and about 7,000 patients as well as
psychiatric disorders including
depression about six 6600 patients in a
range of different kind of complex
diseases that have some genetically
or some or have some kind of polygenic
aside in addition to try to identify the
patient phenotypes based on the icd-9
codes we've incorporated a developed an
incorporated an algorithm that is able
to to accurately predict a the diseases
of different patients based on the
information that found in their
electronic medical records and these are
validated phenotypes with a high
predictive positive value for that the
inside based on the algorithm that we
would develop for these different types
of diseases so this information is also
available to researchers and that
researchers can access this information
to identify a more accurate cohort
rather than relying on the icd-9 or
icd-10 codes which are not always
reflective of true diagnosis in addition
to that we've also we thought we also
used the Charlotte and the Charleston
index to be able to identify healthy
controls within the population with as
part of the samples that are collected
within the biomech so next I'd like to
talk about how we developed different
genomic platforms and genetic
technologies that can be that would
apply to samples that are collected as
part of the biobank and how we
integrated the data that's generated
through these platforms into the
existing infrastructure informational
interest infrastructure that is
available to make to make that type of
data easier for researchers to access
so the approach that the partners
healthcare biobank is is using to be
able to query different Oh mix and
genomics site data is essentially we're
looking at the three main types of omics
data that can be extracted genomics in
the form of gee watts or exo-m slipper
raise as well as whole genome sequencing
transcriptomics looking at RNA seek
looking at the MRNA expression profiles
for different patients as well as
looking at the small RNA peak or the
micro RNA profiles of different patient
cohorts in addition to that one
component another component of the
genomic chianti is to look at the
epigenomic profile of different patients
essentially some through looking at
methylation profiles of different
patient's and so obviously this is a
large large initiative and will require
some time what I what I'd like to focus
on is some some of these the different
components that we'd actually either
began to integrate or planning to
integrate in the near future and to
support these all mix activities and
integration of these type of platforms
the biobank relies on the translational
genomics floor which is a research cord
that's part of the partners healthcare
personalized medicine center the PGC
essentially is accessible to all
researchers researchers at partners
healthcare and it facilitates access the
different omics platform including the
ones that were mentioned in the previous
slide and the PDC the translational
genomics floor has performed many
different types of studies using RNA
DNA for targeted and whole genome
sequencing or exome sequencing as well
as epigenomic type studies either on the
methyl array or by methyl feet and so
the first component to be a genomics
platform component to be integrated into
the Partners Health Partners HealthCare
by Bank is the the G wausau wrexham
slippery and for this we use they mostly
effigy walks XOM separate and this
separate has about 1.6 million Smith and
is run on the alumina I scan or high
scale system and we're able to query 1.6
million Smith's would be option to
extend up to about 22 million markers
with a fairly high conversion rate for
custom content and the content of the
the these markers very different types
of different regions within the genome
and the exome and they are enriched for
medically relevant or clinically
relevant or g wat associated snips and
I've highlighted some of the the the
markers that I thought would be
interesting to cover so these
essentially are multi-ethnic excellent
content includes steps that are that are
that are essentially found in different
races and ethnicities so that we're able
to cover to understand that the ethnic
makeup of our cohort a little bit better
in addition it includes a large number
of G wash markers that have a strong
association association with disease or
have been implicated in different
complex diseases in addition we've
included the markers from clinical
databases
automatically or markers that are
medically relevant curated from
databases such as oh men as well as
clinvar and these essentially include
functional variants and known genes that
are associated with a given trade and
these include lots of function variants
there's wood known farmers form of
genetic relationships as well as this in
human disease areas there was a there
was a focus on essentially variants that
existed within the exomes and in genes
that have been associated with disease
as well as functional variants that are
known to disrupt gene function or to
disrupt the gene expression and so
there's several different components to
being able to integrate a genotyping
workflow to a to a large initiative such
as the biobank genotyping initiative and
it's essentially there's a wet bench
component which essentially just how can
you manage the the sample tracking as
well as the wet bench steps and be able
to attract a given sample through the
different steps and the second part was
once that is generated how can we QC
large batches that are being produced at
such a high throughput and be able to
flag any samples that have their failed
or any marker reactions that are fail
[Music]
so to be able to track samples at the
webex level we use the luminal lymph
system to essentially look at the
two-track samples coming in into the
process and we we also integrated the
alumina lymph system with our own
internal lymph system so that we're able
to track which samples were complete for
for downstream building of those boxes
or for the for those samples as for data
generation once data is generated
essentially the the files or the the
signals that are produced or are
converted in a series of steps to t
genotypes and essentially we look at two
different components of those genotypes
before proceeding with further
downstream analysis and this is what's
shown here in this box right here as
part of the route raw data QC and what
we look at it is to separate components
we look at the sip call rate essentially
for any given snap how well are we able
to make the call at that for that marker
or perhaps net and the other the other
key see that we look at is essentially a
sample based are there any samples that
have a large number of Smith's that are
not being called properly so we can flag
those as well once that's complete their
downstream analysis includes different
components including essentially the
generation of the copy number variants
always in those within within those
samples as well as imputation imputation
across across
the genomic data for that for any given
sample so to be able to capture that
many number of samples and be able to
keep it up properly we developed a
control QC report at a batch level so
that allows us to look at instead of
looking at every single sample that's
coming in were able to kind of keep see
the entire batch as to be able to
identify any sale samples and these
basilan with you see reports essentially
provides a couple of things it looks at
the signal intensity versus the
background intensity for the control
probes across each sample and then we
get an output that is shown here but on
the left so panels a through g provide
the different types of signal to noise
ratio graphs that are that are used for
this QC process in addition we look at
the I graphics produce to look at the
fifth position column rates and anything
that's lower than a ninety-seven percent
call rate is essentially Gras it's
essentially slide and that the grass
that allows us to do that you see is
shown in panel H yeah in addition to the
the graph that are shown here on the
left a supplemental text file is also
produced that actually has the list of
either failed samples or fail snips for
that sample so that we can clearly
identify the sample or snip and follow
up manually if needed on any one of
these components or any one of these
sales reactions so now that we've
generated all this punitive genotyping
data the key is to be able to integrate
it within the electronic medical records
so that we're able to actually use this
data or researchers are able to first of
all access this data and then use it
easily and seamlessly with the existing
electronic medical record data so that
we can so that it promotes discovery or
a health identify force with a given
genotype for different studies as well
as increases our understanding of
complex diseases in terms of their
pensions and please trippy and other
each other and you know making complex
disease type 2 analyses to be able to do
this the biobank IT team has built the
biobank portal which is shown here and
there's several different components
that are communicating with each other
to allow for that integration between
electronic medical record data survey
data from self-reported surveys as well
as sample data and the genotype and the
genotyping data and so the electronic
medical records data is shown here on
the upper left under the the rpd our
tool which collects both the coded data
as well as the text data that is the
provider of part of the EMR in addition
any kind of additional research data
that's been associated with a sample or
with the cohort is also incorporated at
this level the third piece is the
biobank data is also available as part
of this larger bottle Bank portal and
the biobank data that is included as
genomic data that is produced from the
from the arrays but also sample specific
data for each given patient what are the
different samples that are available and
I have this individual been consented
for recontact or as well as the survey
data that is from the full self-reported
surveys all of these are integrated into
the biobank portal the rpd are as our
PBR data allows for the validated
phenotypes so that you can if the
researcher can query and identify a more
accurate cohort a cohort with a larger
accuracy for the disease phenotype that
they're interested in as well as the
identification of controls within that
within the biobank participant and it
also includes all the g wats and the
genotyping data that's been produced
through the G note from the genomic
platform and this is all that together
that integration is not to drive
different research initiatives by a
bipartisan care researchers so what is
the type of different to query tools
that are allowed by the biobank portal
essentially this tool integrates that
this is those different components or
different types of data into one
platform where researchers can come in
define their different parameters for
the cohort there they're interesting so
that they can produce a list of a you
know identify first of all are there any
participants that meet those parameters
and what is their number and what is the
type of samples that are available for
it for for those that are available in
the biobank so for example you can look
at whether the what type of samples are
available is their DNA available for a
given patient or given for individuals
with a certain disease is flattened
available or sterile available also
includes the information from the
self-reported surveys the
the language language preference age of
survey a level of education lifestyle as
low of family history and finally it
also includes the curated disease
population so these are the cohorts
based on either the icd-9 codes or based
on the the validated phenotypes because
that are calculated based on the
algorithm that we've implemented and
finally there's also information on
different specific types of lab results
as well as diagnosis or patient records
that are that may be of interest and in
addition to that there's also access to
being able to identify examples or a
individual that can act as controls for
a different disease states so for
example in this query we're showing
we're asking how many individuals or one
of the samples that are available in the
by bank that have DNA that is a that has
already been collected and extracted and
those individuals have a current or past
history of the type 2 diabetes and so
the researchers would get an output that
looks like this essentially it
identified 160 1654 patients that meet
those two criteria and the query rate is
is fairly quick only 11 seconds to be
able to perform that kind of query
another type of query is to identify a
disease populations that have also for
example
and genotype so in this case we're
looking at individuals with rheumatoid
arthritis that have been genotyped on
the multi-ethnic array genotyping
platform and it identified 223
individuals that we have genotyping data
that have been diagnosed with rheumatoid
arthritis you can also query based on a
snap within the genotyping data so if
you're interested with a particular snip
to identify for example those that might
be susceptible to side effects of a
certain medication or four if you're
looking for a particular marker so that
you can identify patients that can be
part of a clinical trial as the the
snips can also or the marker of interest
can also drive the de query in this case
for example we looked at snips that is
in egfr and that is homozygous and is
basically falls under one of these three
different categories of variant type so
it's either a frameshift or miss sense
or nonsense or you know a
loss-of-function start loss or a stop
loss so different types of essentially a
coding level types of mutations or
variants and the courts that we're
interested in is essentially individuals
that have had different types of
malignancies including a lump lung
cancer malignant neoplasms of bronchus
and lung and difficult diagnosis based
on either be validated phenotypes or the
icd-9 codes and based on that snip
driven query or very different
sighs German query we identify those
individuals within the biobank within
the biobank population that fit those
two criteria and this is just showing
the difference that you can actually
combine different diagnoses or a
different medical different data from
the different from medical records as
well survey information into one query
as one parameter in the query search so
I've shown how we could we integrated
genomics data from slipper raids into
the biobank and this is really
facilitated the identification of
cohorts and made it easier for research
to access this data as part of our
initiative we want to also add another
level of all mixed type data to our to
divide bank portal and you know in line
kind of would be larger integrative
strategy ongoing efforts are focused on
a whole genome sequencing as well as
transcriptomic side data so we're
looking at RNA seek data as well as it's
being able to integrate RNA c5 data as
well as small RNA seek data currently
however we began to investigate the use
of serum and plasma samples from
individuals within the biobank to be
able to do to look at extra somo
[Music]
micrornas analysis so we're looking so
just a quick review of what microRNAs
are small RNA seek analysis entails
essentially we're looking at the role of
the mRNAs and disease mrnas or micro
RNAs regulate the expression of genes
and they do that by one of two mechs
either translational repression or
through mRNA degradation and these mrnas
are important for a wide range of
cellular processes ranging from
proliferation to apoptosis to
generalized or our specific type
cellular functions the mRNAs are a range
of from 18 to 22 nucleotides in length
and currently there's about 2,000 to
2500 known human micrornas and these
microRNAs may have one specific target
or several different targets but it's
estimated that about that the micro RNA
is targeted anywhere from sixty to
eighty percent of the mRNAs and ongoing
ongoing research shows that micro RNAs
can be useful biomarkers in disease so
one example just show that the the role
of micrornas in the in the regulation in
cellular regulation and was inscribed in
the study which essentially looked at a
airway smooth muscle tissue that have
that is associated with asthma and the
NC OPD COPD it was identified that
airway smooth muscle tissue in asthmatic
individuals or an individual with COPD
exhibited hypertrophy which is an
increase in the cell size or hyperplasia
which is an increase in the cell number
through proliferation and the several
pathways are simulated during this
disease process and essentially these
pathways are involved or they
this essentially enhanced cellular
perforation and these include include
cyclin-cdk s apt at 53 CA pathways or
modules and what this study did it was
it identified a micro RNA Mir 10a was a
negative regulator of cellular prefer
proliferation in airway smooth muscle
tissue through the inhibition of the pic
3 CA as well as a downstream inhibition
of cyclones and CD k so the idea that a
micro RNA can regulate a disease can
regulate the the enhancement or the
development of a disease stage show a
you know prove that this should be a
target for either as biomarkers or
prognostic markers or they can also be a
useful and therapeutic approaches one
class of microRNAs are circulating mrnas
and circulating mrnas are essentially
micro RNAs that have been found outside
of the cell and they leave the cells in
one of three mechanisms that are shown
here such as through exosomes or
microvesicles or through lipid the
carrier molecules and these are
relatively and you were in terms of
identify and what their function is in
different cellular processes some of the
some research shows that they're
involved in southeast out communication
or they may be involved in tissue
specific regulation other studies show
that there may be involved in promoting
or inhibiting disease pathogenesis
and so switch the circulating mrnas can
be I can be identified in both serum and
plasma samples and the fact that you can
essentially identify these these
biomarkers from a minimally invasive
sampling structures with blood draw and
makes them advantageous to be able to be
used in different diagnostic biomarkers
studies or prognostic biomarkers studies
as well as be able to use them for
predictive biomarker studies so this so
this the fact that for our biobank
course we have a we have these type of
sample types we have serum as well as
plasma sample size for all patients
within that I've consented and would
select the blood samples from in the by
bank so 11 initiative was to see if we
can also include circulating mrna
biomarkers a type data into our biobank
portal and in in you know in the in that
vein we were trying to decide what is
the best way to kind of approach being
able to test for these these biomarkers
or for circulating mrnas we're robustly
in a high-throughput fashion and so some
of the different platform selected a
selection criteria are outlined here we
would like to be high throughput and
automatable because we're doing a large
number of samples and large number of
batches until we want seamless
integration from sample selection into
the the platform to be able to bec these
microRNAs we want this platform to be
able to interrogate as many mrnas as
possible and to allow for novel mrna
micro RNA discovery in addition to that
we given that we're looking at circle
chelating mRNAs and the amount of
circling mRNAs that are ensuring plasma
samples is very low we want a robust wet
bench workflow that will that will work
well with low input samples and in
addition to that we we would like a
three month poach one pc and data
analysis pipeline that is able to flag
samples that have failed slide get
assays that are specific reactions that
have failed as well as be able to
produce a type of data that can be
easily integrated into the biobank
platform into the biobank portal and the
biobank ancestors larger IC and by
dramatic biobank infrastructure so the
first type of platform to be able to
look at circulating mrnas that we
approach was performing small RNA seek
analysis on circulating mrna and here we
is a figure that just shows the small
RNA speaks library prep work flow it's
pretty much anyone who's familiar with
this it's pretty much a standard library
of prep and TC and sequencing workflow
there however there's a couple of
different things within this workflow
that is unique to circulating mrnas or
that we found challenging when working
when trying to apply this workflow for
circulating mrnas and those are shown by
the two boxes here the first one I
mentioned earlier is the input
consideration with circulating mRNAs
that are extracted from serum and plasma
samples and the amount of mRNAs that are
extracted is so my new that it's
actually difficult to quantify these
using standard quantification methods
such as
ride those hero or nanodrop and so it's
we have one of two options we either
extract and proceed into the small RNA
seek workflow or the second option would
be to try to develop a secondary assay
to be able to solicit to accurately
quantify these which adds additional
cost and labour to that process the
second piece is that within that
extracted sample circulate microRNAs are
actually are a small fraction of the
total sample that's been distracted so
you're getting a small amount and of
extraction material from a serum or
plasma samples and then that small
amount is only a fraction of that
represents small RNA or micrornas that
you're actually interested for this type
of analysis here are different inputs
inputs based on different types of kits
that are then use this small RNA seek
pipeline most kids require a minimum of
one microgram of total RNA and this is a
this is if you're doing a whole white
WBC total RNA extraction with the
circulating mrna you're even getting
less than than what you would get with
with total RNA and the second pieces I
had mentioned earlier is that it's
difficult to accurately quantifying
usually in the standard methods such as
drop in rivalry and the second issue or
consideration when for small RNA seeks
library prep is the size selection step
and it's critical that we're able to
accurately sized select for mrna
libraries and reduce the amount of
contamination whether it be adapter
dimer condemn it contamination or other
RNA species contamination so that we
effectively sequence
the the lead the MRNA and do not do not
minimize the efficiency of the
sequencing however both sides collection
steps that are available for this
workflow are laborious and are very low
throughput and the two methods are I've
written here one is gel Torah fication
essentially you're cutting out the the
fragment that represents the small RNA
on a gel or the other methods to be able
to select is a pure bead purification
both of these are difficult to automate
and require manual efforts and are
limited in the number of samples that
you can do at one time so this figure
shows some data based on the issues that
we countered with five selection so in
this gel on the right on the left the
first three samples are are looking at
and a small RNA speaks that have been
that have been libraries that have been
performed using total RNA at a hundred
nanograms 15 anagrams as well as 25
milligrams and then the second piece and
the other types of samples that we've
also attempted is extractions from
either serum 3 serum samples are shown
here and two plasma samples and what
we're looking for is a slice product as
an mRNA library size product at which is
around 150 to 155 days stairs and with
the total RNA extraction we get a clear
band at the 150 base their size marker
which is the expected library size but
with
the serum and the plasma samples it's
difficult to actually get that type of
them to get that type of library yield
from those types of samples the the
graphs on the right our profiles of the
of these difference for a total RNA
input as well the plasma input and
essentially this this peak right here
represents the small RNA seek library as
the proper size of 155 base pairs but
you can see that there's other types of
contamination these could be RNA a
different RNA species DNA contamination
as well as adapter dimers that's at 133
base pair so this is really difficult to
actually side select for for for small
RNA seek or mrna only libraries with the
plasma samples we get the 155 base there
peach but if you can see it's very small
compared to other Peaks including the
primary diet dimer peaks and other Peaks
that actually we is some kind of
contamination that is it's not really
understood what is private dimer DNA
contamination or other RNA species and
so when we sequence this type of the
sample what ends up happening is a lot
of the sequencing reads that are
generated represents adaptor diamonds
rather than mrnas and so it limits the
amount of analysis like the usability of
that data that it generated from the
sequel so what is the ideal situation to
be a kind of to be able to deal with
these two different technical issues one
thing that we're looking into is to be
able to maximize the input of serum or
plasma sample in the extraction so that
we're able to
uh concentrate the circulating mrnas
that are extracted out of these type of
sample types and the second piece is to
essentially admit the site selection
when possible so we don't have to deal
with the laborious work flow associated
with these and that way we also minimize
the amount of yield that is lost due to
these additional steps this is the type
of QC data that is generated after a
small RNAs each one this panel here
shows the number of reads this panel
here shows the number of reads per
sample all of these are serum samples
appear of our plasma samples except this
one sample right here which is total RNA
and so you can see that we actually did
generate a large number of reads per
sample or variable number of reads
ranging from about 3.7 million reads all
the way to 14 million reads per sample
however the question is of course what
is the percentage of MRI what is the
percentage of reads that I should
represent mrna at the both the
contamination they expected mrna size
after trimming and after cleaning up the
reeds is in the range of 20 to 25 base
pairs and we see that across all samples
so this is a positive indicator but we
also see that there's other contaminants
present in the each one of these samples
when we look at the difference I
wouldn't look at the risk to identify
what is the fraction that is mrna versus
other types of contaminants looking
across the majority of serum samples
it's in the range of fifteen percent as
a comparison that human brain
all the total RNA that was a library
that was generated along side of the
control January closer to thirty percent
of the reeds were truly mrna other
species that are included other
contaminants that are found as you can
see here this is the key showing that
there's a reason that represents genomic
sequences other RNA and a large number
of basically reasons that don't allow
anywhere in the genome or in the
transcriptome and our our theories that
these represent adapter diamonds and
other types of work for workflow related
synthetic illegals that are
contaminating be the final language
construction and within the the RNA
category what other types of rnase are
identified and these are shown here so
there's other small RNA species that are
also represented in the sample including
long non-coding RNAs peewee RNAs and
other types of species that are
currently word are not being used to are
not being analyzed beyond that for
biomarker analysis but to be used in the
future so this is data that has
potential use in the future for right
now we're looking at the micro RNA
species tribe data so looking at the art
and the small RNA chief workflow for the
pure and plasma micro RNA expression
profiling if we were to volley this
platform it is high throughput and
automatable so that's a plus it does
integrate all small RNAs that our
founders in any given sample and it does
allow for novel micro RNA discovery the
the what bench workflow for low input
samples however is one of the challenges
that we face both because of the inputs
the low
issue as well as the the fact that
there's a size selection step that can
be laborious and currently under
currently in we're still working out the
post once you see what it should look
like and one of the parameters that
should be used as well as the type of
output that is generated the downstream
professional expression analysis there
type data that should be produced from
these types of studies and how to best
integrate that within the biobank portal
so that research can easily access that
information and another pro however is
that for the for the web bench component
as well as for the initial GCS the small
RNA seek workflow is the workflow that
were familiar with because of other NGS
library prep methods and the q seas that
are involved with that RTC's that we
understand and can evaluate fairly we
fairly quickly so there are some so
right now that was one platform that we
looked at however we wanted to kind of
address the low input issue because if
we wanted to be if we want to be able to
offer this or to be able to run this on
all by bank participants this issue is
going to come up quite often and there
you know we want to explore ways that we
can avoid this the low input and fear
which serum or plasma crash system so
one thing that we're currently
evaluating at the translational genomics
floor is a library prep system offered
by HCG act and buy HCG molecular and the
name of this system is edge seek and
essentially it facilitates
transcriptional expression profiling
which could be micro RNA profiling or
mrna profiling from samples with low
input or limited extraction yields which
is perfect for something like serum or
plasma
circulating mrnas and the the key the
key items that are associated with this
library process of that kind of
attracted us to it is that it's it has
an extraction free workflow essentially
samples our life and loaded directly
onto the instrument there's no exception
sure up there is no fee fee of
extraction steps and so this helps avoid
yield and biases that might be
introduced during the extraction
procedures the second piece is that is
an NGS base library so that allows us to
use a existing NGS infrastructure in our
lab in addition the fact that you're
looking at you're using read coverage
and read def allow for greater
sensitivity and broader dynamic range
compared with other expression platforms
such as GPCR or micro range and the main
piece that really attracted to attracted
the system to to try to validate the
system is essentially that it can it
does well with low input samples so all
you need is 15 month leaders or plasma
or serum samples to be loaded onto the
system to be able to produce libraries
just in the comparison for small RNA
seek we start with about 200 microliters
of plasma or serum that is extracted to
yield the circulating mrnas and often
we're not able to quantify or TC for
those circulating mrnas the HP chemistry
is based on a quantitatively nucleus
protection assay and essentially it's a
hybridization probe based assay and so
you have different targets RNA targets
across the transcriptome or different
micro RNA targets and the probes are
created or quantitative
so duplicate a nucleus protect
protection probes are synthesized for
those targets and these by to target RNA
the second step would be to eliminate
excess probes and unbound RNAs using an
s-1 assay and then third step is
essentially you you end up with a study
to metric pool of nuclear nucleus target
probes representing the RNA transcripts
or the mrnas mrnas that were in the in
the different samples and the beast
probes are actually are the our sequence
and then quantified to identify a
differential expression of the different
RNA targets so the current probe kiss
that are available are a micro RNA whole
transcriptome which looks at about 2,000
micro RNA transcripts or two thousand
human micro RNA transcripts and several
oncology biomarker panels looking at
mrna transcripts we're currently we're
discussing with HTG ways that we can
develop custom panels for different for
mrna analysis of different types of
pathways as well as the V state so the
workflow for the HTV FC kids is fairly
straightforward you can go from sample
at the expression profiling in three
days again there's no extraction step
you can see here in the in the very left
of this works for the different types of
samples that you can pursue either a
serum or plasma samples as well as ffpe
ffe tissue or even cell culture can be
directly lized and used as input into
the SD system the HP system essentially
helps first of all it targets the
different RNAs that are part of your
kids and and produces ready to speak
with libraries these libraries are then
QC just using our normal or standard NGS
GC analysis and then they're that their
sequence using the my peak and one of
the major advantages in addition to this
you know she won workflow is that acha
jee molecular also has software to be
able to quantify the different probes
and provide a normalized count of across
the different RNA targets or micro RNA
targets and in a very short in a very
short time step so the h so the
advantages of the hdds week is that its
expression free and low input and that's
kind of what is what initially drove us
to look into this and there is an
automated workflow for either 24 samples
or 90s examples which would be
advantageous for by obeying samples and
there is a few line data processing work
flow that is integrated would end if you
need to the the HCG probe set or the
different types of kids the
disadvantages of course are that it
requires additional validation
necessarily a new technology that's out
on the market right now and validations
using standards the unknown workflow
such as qpcr or microwaves needs to be
performed to be able to say yes the
council that are produced using this
workflow actually match other types of
data that's being produced looking at
micro RNAs
and another major limitation is that it
is pro based so you're only targeting a
subset of of mRNAs that are present or
you're not and you're not looking at it
doesn't allow for novel biomarker
discovery at the micro RNA level or at
the MRNA level so with that I'll
summarize the channel art our experience
of integrating genomics platforms into
existing bio-based infrastructure the
biobank essentially are a great way to
advance the initiatives of personalized
medicine through providing essentially
two main things one is access to patient
cohorts and reducing the cost of patient
samples and these and to include genomic
platforms into a as part of the biobank
such as genotyping instructions micro
RNAs requires a assessment at the web
bench level of the by semantic level as
well at the IQ level to be able to
integrate and streamlined these
processes and to be able to facilitate
ease of use by researchers as well as
data access and the third component is
you know looking at novel plop athletes
and platforms may offer additional ways
to utilize biobank samples so that we're
able to identify a diagnostic prognostic
or therapeutic markers of disease and
even so this the limitation to this is
that we only extract DNA pier and plasma
so we want to be able to maximize the
usage of the the usage of the types of
data that is generated from looking at
these samples and
new or existing assets such a small RNA
seek such as the hht GF seek will allow
us to kind of discover novel biomarkers
using these limited types of of sample
types and this I with that I'd like to
acknowledge the large Partners
HealthCare biobank team and many people
within different departments are
involved in in the large initiatives
that's being performed by Partners
HealthCare from IP individual by
informatics teams as well as a large lab
operation speed for these different
workloads and with that I'd like to stop
here and I can take any questions thank
you dr. Elmer for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them in
the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green to an a button of the lower left
of the presentation window dr. Elmer
will interest many questions as time
permits so the anticipation let's jump
in and our first question asked today
are you able to extract RNA from the
same blood sample used from DNA serum
and plasma extraction so that's that's
kind of one of the limitations of having
one type of blood draw and one blood
tube is that we are not able to extract
the RNA from that same blood draw and as
the one of the as part of our larger is
a mixed strategy is to be able to do RNA
seek
and thus now we're looking into ways to
having a second blood draw specifically
in a tube that is to be used for that
aren't extraction so that is kind of one
of the components that let us look at
other China's transcriptomics analysis
strategies and let us to looking at
circulating mrnas as one potential
option would the type of sample fact
that we have thank you for your answer
we have a second question here today and
it asked what kinds of controls are
necessary for circulating mi RNA
analysis experiment so I can you repeat
the question
what let me repeat that for you again
what type of controls are necessary for
circulating in our mi RNA analysis
experiment so for circulating mrnas type
of experiments one thing that we've
added is the total RNA extractions that
way we don't have to worry about the the
low input issue and that acts as a
positive control for our experiments
however it is it's not clear if there's
an internal health keeping control
marker that should be found in all
circulating mRNAs that are extracted
from serum and plasma and that's been an
ongoing validation for us to be odd to
be able to identify a marker that we can
always assess to to be able to establish
whether and it is rich learning mRNA
experiment was successful or not one
thing that we're looking into right now
is using spike in synthetic illegals
that can be kind of track throughout the
experiment and the sequence to be as a
potential control sample specific
control as well as a dynamic range
control for for search link mRNA
experiments but that's still kind of on
going to be able to establish what types
of controls work
thank you doctor amer we have time for
one more question today in this question
asks how will differential expression
data from RNA seek and mi are in a
analysis be integrated into the biobank
quarter so there's several approaches
that we're looking at right now into
what's the best way to kind of integrate
this type of data one one type of data
that's generated from these experiments
are essentially counts by gene and the
other pieces more kind of informative
data in differential expression across
genes however for differential
expression analysis you need a control
group and a and a and a case you know I
case groups to be able to make that kind
of comparison so one approach that we're
thinking about is essentially for each
individual standardizing the kind of
count you know transcriptome counts or
expression counts across the different
genes or different circulating mrnas
that are there are targeted as part of
these workflows for each patient we have
that those counts and then allow the
researchers to kind of create their own
cases or in control groups and and
Cecilia's that comparison as the you
know once the cases and control groups
have have been identified this is course
an ongoing effort and it certainly will
be it's unique from genotyping data
because it requires it requires actually
being able to identify the case control
information before the analysis can
occur so we will you know continue to
work on this and see what is kind of
more suitable for the
sighs of data but at the same time
taking into account that researchers
accessing this data come from variety of
backgrounds and expertise in this type
of analyses and kind of facilitate the
easiest way to be able to approach this
the the case-control questions that
they're interested in I would like to
once again thank you dr. armor for your
presentation do you have any final
comments you'd like to leave with us so
yes first of all thank you for the
opportunity come and present our
experience in integrating omics data
into existing biobank infrastructure and
I think the one kind of final thought
would be that there is a lot of there
are a lot of tools and platforms that
are available to us and one of the key
things as you can see from from this
from this presentation is that you know
having those tools having those
platforms available is only the first
step in being able to use it
meaningfully in the in a larger context
of the body banghard I think that that's
going to be there is that's going to be
a kind of a new experience for for for
any type of the research initiative and
we'll certainly you know change it
evolved over as we as we discover what
is the best way to kind of enhance
research through biobank type data and
with that I appreciate the opportunity
to speak to you all
and I thank you for attending this
presentation if I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we would all
like to take laprez for today's
educational webcast this Web cat can be
viewed on demand through July 2017 la
Bruce will alert you via email when it
is available for replay we encourage you
to share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
I'll see you next time here at labyrinth
goodbye